- Everyone is laughing
at me but I feel cute.
Stop laughing! (laughs)
(catchy dance music)
- I think she's kind of a
bad ass in terms of style.
- She likes to party,
she likes to get down,
she likes to stick her tongue out.
(Ahhhh) She's like the
Michael Jordan of girls.
- She brings it, every time she gets
on camera, she does something weird.
- It's my show.
- Hannah Montana equals lots
of stuff, she dances and sings.
- Feel like a Disney princess.
- She was a kid and now she's an adult.
- I'm a superstar.
- What's going on now?
- Student by day, rock
and roll star by night.
- This is the first time in my life
I've ever been couture, it's crazy.
- I think my balls are showing right now.
- (laughs)
- I feel like a very
sexy abominable snowman.
- The pasties don't leave
much to the imagination.
I wanna go to the gym
one day dressed like this
and just hit like a deep squat set.
- I feel oddly beautiful.
- There is a lot of skin showing.
How do you go anywhere dressed like this?
- How we feeling out there?
- This is the one where she like invented
sticking your tongue out sideways, right?
- I feel like I got kicked
out of Chuck E. Cheese.
- I like how the like ears
are kind of like nipple flaps.
- Like I don't know why
they suddenly labeled
what she did as twerking cause
people have been doing that forever.
- And we stick our tongue out (blaaah).
- I was doing that when
I was a teenage boy
and I just called it Unh.
- Do I have it?
- I feel like she's almost like
our generation's Madonna, right?
She loves to shock, she loves to outrage
with kind of these clothing statements,
these fashion statements, these
in your face fashion moves.
I think she is a very brilliant
salesperson of her own brand.
- If there's one thing she is, it's brave.
- I totally get it, I
totally get what Miley Cyrus
is trying to do, she's
trying to be original,
she's trying to stand out and it works.
- She had this image of like
the good girl preteen star
and she like said (bleep) that
and didn't care what was gonna happen
and it wound up being
a big success for her.
So I think it was a bold
move and it was a cool move.
(laughter)
- [Voiceover] Get that on
camera, get that on camera.
- What did you, what did you just say?
(laughter)
(whoosh)
(hinge squeak)